bonjour et merci d'être en direct avec
nous sur rt france plusieurs annoncé
hier de christophe castaner le ministre
de l'intérieur qui propose donc
notamment que chaque soupçons avérés de
racisme dans les forces de l'ordre
entraîne une suspension la formation
aussi aux questions de discrimination
devrait être accentuée ce que cela vous
semble aller dans le bon sens d'abord je
note que castanet il a dit qu'il croyait
en la justice des tribunaux et parents
twitter mais il a quand même fallu une
énorme mobilisation pas pour qu'il
évoque ans un sujet qu'il avait d'abord
ignoré alors qu'ils étaient soulevés par
jacques toubon pas a reconnu par la
société civile
donc de ce que je vois de ces de ces
propositions donc une réforme d
inspection du ministère de l'intérieur
pour plus de cohérence et d'indépendance
et une suspension systématiquement
envisagée pour chaque soupçons avérés
d'actes ou de propos racistes
ce qui est quand même c'est à dire que
même en cas de certitude d'un chaos de
propos d'actes racistes la suspension ne
sera qu envisagée en fait il faut pas
qu'elles soient systématiquement visage
et auquel soit systématique tout
simplement
et par rapport à la technique du placage
d'entre al alors lui dit que ce n'est
pas une vraie technique en soit même si
les gendarmes d'ailleurs qui ont qui
avait interpellé
adama traoré ont eux mêmes dit dans dans
leurs propos dans le rapport qu'ils
avaient fait un plaquage mais centrale
donc ça va bien dire que ça existe en
tant que tel lorsqu'on apprend c'est que
ce qui sera interdit maintenant c'est la
technique d'étranglement oui c'est très
surprenant qui est même une pique nique
d'étranglement qui existent et qui porte
un tel nom aussi assumer enfin par
rapport à la question des violences
policières même s'il refuse le mot lui
c'est qu'il dit c'est que ce sont des
brebis galeuses c'est que c'est quelque
chose qui est extrêmement minoritaire
qui n'est pas admis dans la culture de
la police et que donc baril va renforcer
finalement de la prévention mais moi en
tout cas personnellement ce qui m'a
toujours interpellé
à la fois dans les groupes facebook qui
ont éclaté avec ses révélations
accablantes de groupes facebook où il ya
des milliers de personnes dedans qu'ils
sont censés être des fonctionnaires de
police ou dans les vidéos qui circulent
sur les réseaux sociaux de violences
policières à la fois complice gilet
jaune ou dans les quartiers où pendant
le confinement et sait c'est que les
personnes les policiers qui connecte ou
bien des des prises de paroles racistes
dans les groupes facebook ou des actes
de violence vraiment gratuite genre
passait devant quelqu'un qui est menotté
le gifler ou ferme balayette gratuite
etc
ces gens là le fond à côté de leurs
collègues et ils n'ont pas peur d'être
jugés par leurs collègues parce que même
quand castanet redit que dans un groupe
de huit mille personnes c'est pas vrai
que nos emails personnes ont dit des
choses raciste mais ça veut dire que les
personnes qui l'ont dit se sentait en
sécurité de dire devant des milliers de
leurs collègues des choses raciste et ça
veut dire de ce que j'ai vu des vidéos
de violences policières que les
collègues qui donne un coup de taser à
la jeune à la jeune ramatoulaye ou chi
chi chi chi qui font qu'ils étaient
revenus sur les pattes qui en rendant à
quelqu'un on a vu ça encore récemment ou
qui se moque d'un individu qui l'on
reproche repêchés dans la seine etc
ils font ça devant leurs collègues parce
que on voit bien qu'ils n'ont pas peur
d'être jugés par leurs collègues
d'ailleurs dans les vidéos de violences
policières ne voient pas leurs collègues
s'interposer il dit à dire attention là
tu es en train de faire une bavure est
en train de perdre ton sang froid
donc c'est pour ça que je pense que
c'est malheureusement des comportements
qui sont pas forcément stigmatisé en
interne mais qui sont contraires toléré
il y a une forme d'impunité
c'est ce que vous dénoncez quelles
seraient vos propositions pour un pour
combattre toute forme de racisme dans
les rangs de la police
il faudrait que ça vienne d'en haut
c'est à dire qu'il faudrait que c'est
que les policiers sache que le
gouvernement ne serait pas en solidarité
avec eux si jamais ils commettent des
actes de violences policières de deux
contrôles au faciès et c est moi j'ai
trouvé quand même qu'il y avait beaucoup
de choses symboliques dans le discours
de castaner même si les mesures
n'allaient pas assez loin
il faut une vraie enquête et des vraies
mesures contre le contrôle au faciès
il faut que les policiers portent
systématiquement c'est très très loin
d'être leur cas le port du rio qui
permet de les de les identifier il ne
faut surtout pas faire passer la loi
d'eric ciotti qui demande qu'on
interdise de filmer les fonctionnaires
de police parce que malheureusement
chaque fois qu'il ya eu des scandales
c'est parce que ça a été filmé il n'y
aurait pas eu d'histoire de mouvement
après la mort de georges flight si on
l'avait pas vu cette violence policière
se commettre sous nos yeux et c'est
parce qu'il ya eu et notamment pendant
le mouvement des filets jaunes et
pendant le confinement beaucoup beaucoup
de personnes qui ont pris le risque de
films et que finalement c'est devenu un
sujet politique qui intéresse les élus
et les personnes au pouvoir et je pense
que le plaquage ventrale doit être
complètement interdit parce que de fait
c'est ce qui a fait la mort de plusieurs
personnes que ce soit cédric julia que
ce soit adama traoré est en tout cas il
ya toujours des certaine entre expertise
qui disent que c'est bien une x
n'asphyxie positionnelle qui a engagé
par cette position d'un mot le
gouvernement ces derniers jours ça
s'affiche clairement mobilisés sur ces
questions en revanche emmanuel macron se
fait beaucoup plus discret est ce que
selon vous il devrait prendre clairement
la parole sur ses thèmes vin lui dans sa
conception du présidentialisme pour lui
quand il ya des questions importantes
c'est lui qui prend la parole on l'a vu
par exemple par rapport à la crise
sanitaire en tant que féministe on avait
par ailleurs regretté qu'il ne prenne
pas la parole sur la grande cause du
quinquennat qui sont les féminicides il
avait délégué au premier ministre et je
pense que en tout cas lui il eut la
tendance à monter au créneau quand pour
lui c'est une question d'état qui qui va
devoir impulser des prises de position
importante sur le long terme
donc pour moi oui pour donner toute sa
solennité son caractère officiel au fait
de
de prendre en charge cette problématique
si vous vous souvenez pendant la crise
sanitaire l'huile donner l'orientation
générale
et puis après le ministre de le premier
ministre ministre de l'intérieur de mai
les mesures donc en fait il interprétait
sa direction générale avec des mesures
et je pense que c'est ce qu'il fait
qu'il faudrait maintenant il faudrait
que hemani mal qu'on prenne des
engagements comme il l'a fait quand il
était candidat contre les violences
policières
merci d'avoir pris le temps de répondre
à nos questions fatima benomar je
rappelle que vous êtes co fondatrice des
effrontées